[Music]
you know we love showing you Disney
Princesses reimagined in different life
situations and this is one of those we
just couldn't resist wait until you see
the most amazing picture of Mulan and
Shang don't forget to subscribe to the
things and give this video a big thumbs
up now let's check out 10 Disney
Princesses reimagined as parents Ariel
look at this picture isn't it neat
wouldn't you think that area would make
a perfect parent
this photo belongs to the insanely
talented Isaiah Stephens whose images
will be featured throughout this video
but look at this adorable picture looks
like
Ariel's son is giving her a hard time
and she's really not amused he seems to
be having the time of his life though
and we absolutely love that his hair is
just as red and fiery as Ariel's the
question is does he have a mermaid tail
when he gets to the ocean we can't get
over Ariel's face though Tiana
here's another adorable picture by the
talented Isaiah we all know Prince
Naveen was way too free-spirited for
Tiana and then it took a long time for
the two to actually get used to the fact
that they coexist but it all seemed to
have worked out well and this happy
ending would have made it even better
check it out looks like these two got an
adorable baby but it seems that karma
finally got Naveen for not being honest
with Tiana in those early stages of
their relationship and Tiana seems to
really get a kick out of the entire
situation way to go kid Elsa before we
check out some other artists here's
another photo by the talented Isaiah now
this one is just way too adorable we
already know Elsa would be a fantastic
mother and this cute photo just proves
it that baby boy also looks like he's
having the ice Queen's magical powers
which is pretty cool
now Elsa can teach her kid to control
his powers early on and he'll never have
to go through what Elsa did but we bet
he's still a lot of trouble who knows
maybe we'll actually see this play out
in the official frozen movies in the
future Jasmine okay this is seriously
turning out to be the most adorable
video ever
just like with Elsa we all know jasmine
would be a good mom and deviantART user
dark matter Nova proved that there's
some truth to that statement isn't
Jasmine's son just the cutest they look
so comfortable and just look at that
loving look in Jasmine's eyes he can
tell that the little
we'll still have an amazing life ahead
of him the real question is do they
still have the magical carpet somewhere
in the house come on Disney we want a
live-action version of this Merida
speaking of adorable if there's one
Disney princess we want to see as a
parent it's definitely Merida
she was definitely one of the first
princesses with a different story so she
deserves to have the spotlight the user
wolf - Terrier from deviantART created
one of the most adorable images ever
showing what Merida would look like as a
mother and her child is absolutely
adorable although we can't imagine the
kid will probably have red curls just as
wild as her mother's we can totally see
Merida teaching her kids some important
lessons on girl power and
self-confidence
Belle while we're on the subject of
important lessons we vet Belle would
definitely teach our kids the importance
of having Beauty on the inside the
amazing Isiah Stephens did an absolutely
amazing job with this one look how
adorable Belle look sticking care of her
baby they both look so peaceful we have
a feeling her baby boy would be just as
strong minded as Bella's and hopefully
he'll also love books just as much as
his mother but seriously can you imagine
the Beast holding and gently playing
with a tiny baby now that's something
we'd want to see Cinderella but wait
we're not done yet if you want to see
cute make sure to stick around for the
final four princesses we love Cinderella
and she deserves nothing but happiness
and CIN ISA ante from deviantART made
sure that's exactly what she gets
check out her adorable family of course
there's Prince Charming but look at her
cute kids so far most of our princesses
had a baby boy but it seems like
Cinderella has a girl and the boy the
deviantART user did an amazing job with
this one and we absolutely love that the
boy looks like he'd be a troublemaker
Rapunzel that's right our favorite long
haired ghoul just got a makeover but
it's not exactly the one you'd expect
deviantART user Olympique - Dames
reimagined Rapunzel as pregnant but this
version of Rapunzel isn't free or safe
with her family she's still with Mother
Gothel who doesn't seem very happy well
let's be honest she was never really
happy do you think she told her she's
looking kind of chubby
before she realized her so-called
daughter is pregnant honestly this is
kind of terrifying so let's just move on
to the next one shall we
hopefully this version of Rapunzel got
out of Mother Gothel Clause to Snow
White's sunny Santa from deviantART also
beautifully reimagined what Snow White
would look like as a parents Snow White
ends up with her version of Prince
Charming
but in this picture she also seems to
have an adorable daughter we haven't
seen a lot of Disney daughters in this
video so we're glad that at least one
more artists decided to continue the
princess legacy just look at Snow
White's adorable blue-eyed daughter how
cute is this she has the exact same
hairstyle too now this is what we call a
true Disney happy ending
Mulan but one of our favorite Disney
parent versions comes once again from
Isaiah Stephens seriously you have to
check out his amazing art even though
Mulan and Shang are still expecting the
baby we thought to add this in because
it's one of the most amazing photos ever
just look how loving they are you know
that this baby will turn out to be one
of the most amazing and powerful babies
ever just imagine having Mulan as your
mother and hearing about all the
inspiring adventures she went on when
she was younger
seriously Disney we need to follow up on
all these Disney Princesses and their
lives and that's all for our video who's
your favorite Disney Princess let us
know in the comments thanks for watching
see you next time
[Music]